[Applause]
less than four months ago these people
the tory faithful hailed boris johnson
as the chosen one remaking british
politics in a conservative image
now a man hailed for breaking labour's
red wall waiting to find out his fate
which might be determined by the people
here who he helped get elected for the
first time in 2019. one of boris
johnson's oldest friends in parliament
reminded them that they owed everything
to him
my message to all those colleagues who
came to the house of commons for seats
that in my 35 years of membership of the
conservative party we never held and i
never thought for a moment until 2019 we
have a woodhold that they are here
because of the leadership and the
connection between boris johnson and the
british people
knowing you want to oust to pm is very
different to knowing who should come
next we don't know whose hats are going
to be in the ring when we know then each
and every one of us on the conservative
benches will have to exercise the
judgment but i certainly wouldn't wish
to
begin to try and do it until i know who
the runners and riders are
talking to dozens of tory mps most think
that boris johnson's time is up that's
the settled will of the party i keep
being told
but there's much less agreement on when
he should be ousted from office or how
and as for who well there's certainly no
agreement about what should come next
and it's through that eye of a needle
that boris johnson could just spy a
glimmer of hope for his own future
one of those who was alongside theresa
may as she was being ejected from number
10 warns mps may take longer to actually
knife a sitting prime minister than they
tell people there's quite a difference
between
moaning and complaining and grumbling to
the media and then actually putting the
letter in
and then deciding well having thought
all the angles through i think the best
thing is to replace the prime minister
with another and you're never quite sure
who that other is
few prime ministers go at a time of
their choosing many depart after losing
elections or votes none in recent times
has gone because of their own conduct
sam coates sky news